all right Hammers and sickos that's the
focus of tonight's
angle I know it was all hammer and
sickos in San Francisco since the
arrival of China's dictator Xian pin
Americans desperate to honor and impress
him decided to make him feel right at
home now that is a flag that represents
subjugation oppression and
persecution not just to the Chinese who
fled but for those who have no way out
of China and for a second in watching
this welcome that she received on our
soil I thought that I was watching my
old favorite flick from the mid 80s Red
[Music]
[Applause]
Dawn well seriously watching the Biden
cabinet the regime media these American
plutocrats Fawn all over X I'm sorry
it's just
disgusting did they forget that China
did what it did during Co not only did
they cover up the origins of the virus
that killed Millions but also with
brutal efficiency they locked down
hundreds of millions of their own people
in their own homes and sprawling
apartment
complexes the only thing Chinese
citizens could do was to scream on their
balconies at
[Applause]
night think of the 2 million Wagers who
are languishing in what they call
re-education camps their internment
camps pere's directives they sit there
tortured by guards including some of
them who've actually escaped the guards
I'm talking about to tell the world
about the rampant human rights abuses
that occur did the police officers use
electric batons to shock prisoners yeah
yes everyone uses different
methods for years stories of arbitrary
arrests unspeakable cruelty and mass
internment camps have been trickling out
of China's shinjang region if you want
people to confess you use the electric
baton we would tie two electrical wires
on the tips and set the wires on their
genitals while the person is tied up
the result is
better now apparently Joe Biden the
press and the CEOs who paid up to
$40,000 to be at a banquet for the
dictator they're not phased by any of
this or by what's been done to the
Christians in China whose churches have
been bulldozed on G's
orders is the Google CEO also not
concerned about what's happened to Hong
Kong CEO CEOs who've been disappeared by
China or the ones who've been thrown
into solitary confinement for years like
Jimmy
lie all these people for money have a
convenient case of Amnesia because
they're so desperate to work on their
relationship with China business execs
want to expand operations they want to
export more American jobs overseas and
sell more stuff there and the Biden
ventriloquist well they want a beautiful
green future with China that's funny
of course this requires improving the US
China
relationship but the truth is Biden's
already compromised given how much money
his son Hunter made there for no
discernable Talent other than being the
then vice president's son now you all
remember during the 2020 election
President Biden denied all of the money
that was made nothing was unethical my
son has not made money in terms of this
thing about uh what are you talking
about China
it took the Press years to finally admit
that Joe was not telling the truth about
that and why because Hunter himself
testified that he had in fact made a
substantial sum of money from Chinese
interests plus of course this had all
been confirmed by documents emails and
so forth found on Hunter's laptop which
the Press claimed was Russian in
disinformation again conveniently during
the
campaign so when someone repeatedly
reveals himself through his bad
actions don't make excuses for him
believe what he does do not believe what
he says but despite all that we know
about what China's done and supporting
Russia as I was talking to with with
trace or stealing our intellectual
property dumping cheap products here
committing
genocide Biden thinks X is a Straight
Arrow to host you in the United States
is a great honor and a pleasure there's
no subst to to face tace discussions
I've always found our discussions
straightforward and Frank and I've
always appreciated
them I think he meant to say the
business that they sent his son well
that was always
appreciated all right let's be candid
here this is a really sad day for those
of us who remember when America stood
for Freedom when American leaders did
not gravel before dictators when the
world saw us
that you know that that that America was
Rising you know not one country that was
stumbling toward a future with a with a
dictator like X someone becoming almost
X's
puppet but this is what our leaders want
and unless we get new leaders in
2024 there's no reason tonight to
believe things are not going to get even
worse and that's the angle hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox new YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else